It was cold here in Hollywood today.
We're having what they call a cold snap.
It's so cold, I had to wear two tank tops to work today.
The high today was 55 degrees.
Can you imagine?
And everyone is freaking out.
Last night, the local news here in LA,...
...the local news in LA is hilarious.
We really have no idea how silly we would look if people in places like Milwaukee...
...saw how we react when the temperature drops below 55.
For the past 24 hours,...
...this is the sort of thing they've been saying on our local weather reports.
Are you ready for probably two of the coldest nights...
...you've ever experienced in Southern California?
And look at the temperatures: only into the 50s.
Cold, cold, cold coming our way.
Beyond cold.